okay david reed says
first of all travis respect you for
sticking with your story i myself have
witnessed
a ufo in majorca in september 1995. i've
only discussed it with my wife question
considering how long it took you to come
to terms with come to terms with your
experience do you think that the human
race is ready to accept for some time
now that we've been observed by
technologically advanced intelligence
i do think that uh humans are getting
closer and closer to that this whole
uh big lead up to a big uh release of
information from in congress uh
was sort of a
letdown it wasn't
as forthcoming as it was promised but i
the fact that it existed at all is a
major step forward
and um
basically
to have official channels acknowledge
that there
is something there that isn't ours and
uh
um
whether they just uh
their conscience got to them they
decided to come clean and tell us
i don't think that's the case it was
just a matter of
the evidence is piling up too high to
rely on ridicule and dismissing the
witnesses
was not
reducing their credibility it was
reducing the government's credibility
so they
you know finally acknowledge
yes there's things we can't
explain in terms of uh
conventional
whatever so that was a step forward and
you know it's interesting it was kind of
a
social engineering kind of a thing
um
that when these announcements were made
they came late on a friday
and that's normally what
they do
when um
they want to
something to be out there
but to get
a minimum of attention
uh it sort of gets ignored until the
next news cycle and by monday there'll
be a whole pile of other things to
divert attention so it doesn't
doesn't uh
it's a
a soft bombshell